- [Voiceover] All right, go for it.
(single clap)
- Ah, what it do, party people?
Welcome to another episode of Real Mature.
It's a show that we
make about things you do
when you grow up, and one of the things
that happens to you when you grow up is
the way you party changes.
So, we have three different stories
about, well, partying.
The first one involves Keith.
- (groans) Let's do this, Henry.
- (mumbles) Let's get it.
All right, let's go!
Let's go, let's go!
- All right!.
- [Voiceover] All right, later camera.
(mellow electronic music)
- So, today's episode is
about the way you party
and how it changes as you get older,
so the first piece is by Keith.
- Yeah, so for an experiment,
me and my two friends
who are about 29 and 30
went back to my college
to try and party like we did
when we were 20, 21, et cetera.
- [Voiceover] Ten-four, that's what
I was gonna let you know.
- So, it took (laughs)
us less than 20 seconds
to get stopped by the police.
- My name is Brian Wohl.
I am a handsome 30-year-old man.
- So, I'm Keith.
I'm a beautiful 27-year-old boy.
- I'm Marc Muszynksy.
I'm 29, looking fine.
- And I am back at my alma mater.
- To party like we used
to, see if we can do it,
see if it's still fun.
So, we're gonna go pick up Marc.
Marc I met in college, so
he's gonna get in the car
and he's gonna tell you
about his whole experience.
- Marc!
- [Voiceover] Hey.
- You go take a seat by Henry.
- All right, what's up man?
- Sitting by you.
- All right, are you
guys ready to watch this?
- Yeah.
- Let's do it.
- All right.
- So, we used to drink,
like many college students
are fond of, and we used to play
a game called "Scepter," or I've heard
it's also called "Wizard Staff."
Scepter, where you
would tape the next beer
to the top of the one you just finished,
and so as you drank, you'd slowly get
a longer and longer scepter,
and I am what I think
is colloquially known as a "wimp,"
never got one that was more than,
probably seven was my max.
- I like how you feel bad about
having only drank seven beers.
(Marc laughs)
- So, I think tonight, because
now I'm older and wiser,
and can think more strategically,
I think I can get to eight.
- Can I just say, for the record,
this is a stupid goal.
(laughs)
- They're all stupid, Henry.
None of them are gonna
impress you (laughs).
(everyone laughs)
- Five beers, five beers.
This scepter has five beers.
- So, we're on five.
I was wandering around the party
doing dramatic, what, in my brain,
I assume was GoPro party cinematography.
So, what do you look for
in a party companion?
- Someone who is rocking
it just as hard as I am.
- Who's this guy?
- (laughs) His name is
Brian, but his nickname
amongst his college friends is "Stick."
- I mean, he looks glorious.
- Yeah (laughs), he's an awesome guy.
- The thing it makes me
think of as a 32-year-old
is I don't party with
anyone like Stick anymore.
- Yeah.
I was able to get to eight beers,
which is, I guess, my new record.
- Look how happy you
are with your scepter.
- (laughs) I was thrilled.
So, thanks for the swing by memory lane.
- Ah!
- Oh no!
(onlookers laugh)
- Did going back and partying
like you did 10 years ago
make you wish you were
still 10 years younger?
- It made me glad I did it once,
but it actually just made
me thrilled that I'm not.
Although those parties are fun,
when you're done with that lifestyle,
and you go out into a
bigger, more adult world,
all the rewards for everything
you do during the day
get so much bigger that that stuff
is just as fun as partying.
- That's very grown-up.
The next video was a
video that I pretty much
thrust upon our intern, Kane,
and two of our other interns.
I brought them into a meeting.
They didn't know what was gonna happen,
and I said, "In seven hours, you are going
"to have a dinner party ready at one
"of your guys' houses for three
"of the senior producers on our team."
- We have no idea what
we're (laughs) gonna do yet.
- I'm on Pinterest right now
(Kane laughs)
(mumbles)
- Going with a California-ish theme.
- Yeah, the theme is fresh.
- We spent two hours at Trader Joe's
looking for stuff.
- We spent two hours
at Trader Joe's.
- Okay, so after buying the most random
assortment of things at Target...
Can anyone tell me which
one is a serving tray?
I am on my way to Kane's house,
and we're gonna do this thing.
- All right, we're starting to cook now.
We have all our stuff ready.
We moved the table down.
(acoustic blues music)
- I think we started off slow.
We did take a 20-minute nap earlier
because we were tired (laughs).
- I honestly think things have been
going pretty smoothly.
I feel like we've divvied
up everything pretty equally
and we've gotten along really well.
- I burnt the onions.
- Oh my god (laughs).
- (laughs) We can't use this.
(both laugh)
- Sorry, I tried a new
recipe that I'm not used to.
Actually, I'm gonna do that.
Okay, fax the original recipe.
- Guys, where's the vodka?
(triumphant orchestral music)
- Are you supposed to be putting them
(laughs) into the pot that hot?
- Yeah, why not?
- Oh, maybe not.
(laughs)
- Wait, what?
- Everyone's gonna get drunk.
Just kidding (laughs).
- I hate everything right now.
(Kane laughs)
- [Voiceover] Do you know
what waits behind you,
behind that door right there?
- Yeah, a dinner party thrown by interns.
- Them just trying is probably enough,
but we'll see.
I don't know.
Maybe it'll be a disaster.
- Yeah, I'm curious what
we're gonna talk about.
You know?
What do the interns have to say?
(knocks several times)
- Hello.
- Hey, guys.
- Hi.
- Welcome.
- Welcome to our dinner party.
- Oh my goodness.
(lively string music)
- Feel free to grab a seat.
We made some Moscow mules for you.
- Oh, great.
- Oh shit, the fire's still on!
- So, what are these things here?
- These are mini quiches.
- Yes, and they are made
of spinach and artichoke,
and parmesan, and mozzarella.
- Mozzarella.
- Is there egg also?
- Yeah, there is egg.
- That's like a given.
- That's the main ingredient.
- There's no crust.
- They are crustless.
(everyone laughs)
- Yeah, they're crustless.
- So, this is salad.
- I'm trying to get the
rest of the food together
so that when it's time for dinner,
it can happen seamlessly
and they don't have to wait.
You know, Henry's a tough one.
- [Voiceover] How do you think it's going?
- I think it's going well,
just gotta get the convo
flowing a little bit.
Once they finish those Moscow mules,
I think everyone will be A-okay.
- This is our big finish.
We have the salmon and the rice,
and then the vegetables.
- [Voiceover] This looks amazing.
- Yeah, you guys are being too polite
but thank you.
- [Voiceover] Same.
(laughs)
(piano-led R&B music)
- What do you think of the salmon, guys?
- It's really great.
- Fucking delicious.
- Glad you like it.
- It's nice and subtle.
- It's right on.
- This is a lot of food.
- It's a lot of work.
- I am so proud of these.
I have never used a little
pastry frosting thing before.
- My friend had invited me over one time.
She's like, "Dinner's at five."
I was like, "What?"
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, I find that odd,
to be honest with you.
- Like, why is it so early?
- Who eats at five o'clock?
- Yeah, it's weird.
- It's weird.
- Woah.
- So, Sophia made this with love.
(laughs)
- Then have a fun game after this.
- Oh, there's a game.
- Yeah.
(laughs)
- You can't use (mumbles).
(several people laugh)
- No, you're doing your best.
- Oh, wake the fuck up.
- Yeah!
- Okay, Briana.
- It's not time yet, Kane.
(Kane laughs)
- Too hot.
(several people laugh)
- Okay.
You're feeling it.
You're feeling the drinks, right?
- Yeah, well you're
definitely feeling the drinks.
- There were like four more
courses than I thought.
I thought it was just quiche,
and I would've been like, "Yeah, great.
"That's awesome."
- Good job, kids.
- Good job, guys, but it just kept going,
and that's what was great about it.
- The vibes were good, the food was good,
and it was just all
about having a good time
and being together.
- [Voiceover] I can't believe this is
your first time doing this.
- [Multiple people] Thank
you so much for coming.
- [Multiple people] Thanks for having us.
That is very adult, that's true.
- Buh-bye.
- [Voiceover] All right,
so what was the most
stressful part for you guys?
- I think there was a moment when
it was close to the time
when people were coming,
and we were just all in the kitchen--
- Yeah.
- And my eggs burned (laughs).
(laughs)
- The eggs and the onions burning
was Kane's lowest moment.
- That was my lowest moment.
(everyone laughs)
I had to pour it all out.
- Yeah.
- And redo the rice.
- It was a pleasant evening.
I feel like that's such
an adult thing to say.
- So, that was a great video.
I think we should go see BWo
and find out how his experience was.
- Yeah, let's head to that place
where that guy died in his yard.
- (laughs) What?
- You can catch it in Frozen
Pizza Party Tour 2k-15.
- [Voiceover] What's up, BWo?
- Hey.
- Hey, what up man?
- All right, so we are going to watch
your experience now of what it was like
going back to party like
you did 10 years ago.
- Okay.
My goal for tonight is to
try and take over the party.
I'm going to try and get
people to do activities,
to join me, and just make
the whole event about me.
Who will play us in beer pong?
(high-pitched, sped-up talking)
- BWo's having a good time.
- Behind your back.
- Do it again.
(group cheers)
- Did you care what the college students
thought of you as you were partying?
- I wanted to have the most fun possible,
and generally, having
the most fun possible
is getting as many people
together to share that fun.
- [Voiceover] All right, Bwo.
How are you feeling?
- I'm all right.
I haven't had my coffee yet.
- Who's this bearded
man in the background?
- I was wondering when you guys
would notice the naked man in the bed.
- Who's that?
- Yeah, is this
the first time you've found him?
- I was able to achieve
my goals, just about.
I got everybody to chant some things.
(unintelligible shouting)
- [All together] Down the pipes!
- We were able to sing
some songs at the party.
- [Voiceover] Goodbye
gray skies, hello blue!
Oh wait, we can't sing that song.
It's copyrighted.
(laughs)
- Got a dance party
going, so that was good.
I'm staying.
- [Voiceover] Staying in college?
- Yeah.
- [Voiceover] You'll keep partying here?
- [Voiceover] Into it?
- Yeah.
- [Voiceover] Nice.
- I'm just staying.
- [Voiceover] Great, that's cool.
- He's staying.
- Wait, wait.
Is that Stick?
- Yeah (laughs).
- That's Stick.
- We love Stick.
You know, Stick is like
this super party bro,
but he's also the sweetest
man at that school.
- He looks like Zac Efron in Neighbors.
(laughs)
- I got the Maui Wowie,
which has jalapenos,
ham, cheese, and pineapple.
I had such a great time eating that food.
It's fabulous.
Very real.
But this morning, I am feeling that food.
- [Voiceover] How did you
feel at the end of the night?
Like, successful, tired?
- I felt incredibly successful.
- At this point, we've outlasted
most of the actual college students.
- Yeah.
- That's great.
You guys outlasted the college students?
- Yeah, man.
- Do you want to party like this more
now that you've had a taste of it?
- Absolutely not.
No, no.
- All right, we'll go
on to the next segment.
Who here knows who Andrew W.K. is?
- I do.
- Andrew W.K. is a rock musician.
He's turned himself into the world's
foremost authority on partying,
but he almost a philosophy of partying.
So, we asked our friend,
comedian Greg Barris,
to interview him at the
Everything Is festival
in Portland a couple weeks ago,
and find out some of his
amazing rules for partying.
- Hey, it's Greg Barris for BuzzFeed.
You know, from the internet,
talking with Andrew W.K.
about partying as an adult.
- Hello, how are you?
- I'm doing good, how you doing?
- Fine, thank you.
- How did you become
an expert on partying?
- Well, by doing it primarily,
by engaging in a celebratory mindset,
but primarily, you can declare yourself
to take on an endeavor, so I said,
"I wanna be good at partying,"
and so, lo and behold, I was.
- Why'd you pick partying?
- To get cheered up.
- Oh, so you were un-cheered.
- I struggled with that consistently.
I definitely wanted to cheer myself up.
This partying mindset has helped
with that a great deal, and it's been
the motivation for my life mission.
I don't want to say it
kills two, but it flutters
two birds with one gust of wind.
- That is beautiful.
- Thank you.
- Am I too old to party?
- Well, no.
I would only say someone would be too old
if there's parts of their physique
which has grown decrepit, but even then,
partying can actually
help bolster the body.
If you're 99 years old, and your body
has grown decrepit and withered,
for example, there was a gentlemen
on the airplane today
that had two crutches,
and he was quite elderly, but
he was still hardy in spirit,
so his partying may be less physical
and more spirit-based, and then someone
like a young child who is only scampering,
and whose soul hasn't
developed that much yet
because they haven't lived that long,
at least in this embodiment,
maybe they're a more physical party.
- Yeah.
- They're just running amok.
- So, like I'm in my thirties,
I get tired easily, I can't
party like the way I used to.
What are some ways to
combat party fatigue?
- Well actually, being
fatigued can count as partying.
- Oh.
- So, resting...
- Oh, okay.
- Sitting,
like you're doing now, laying.
- Napping.
- Napping, but nap hard.
- For people with a more
conventional lifestyle,
like a day job, how do they integrate
partying into that lifestyle?
- You have usually eight hours of work,
hopefully that you can
take some kind of pride in.
Even if you hate the
job, you can still try
to do a good job at what you hate.
Eight hours of rest, or
some version of that,
and then you hope to have eight hours
to kind of do whatever else,
and that's the precious time.
So really, if you only have that precious
eight hours of your life,
you can make that count,
and really, really sort
of live in that slice,
that third, or something.
- Or something.
- Always "or something."
- Yeah, there's more
something all the time.
- Always.
- That was pretty cool.
- Yeah, pretty good.
- So, are you ready to
watch your party experience?
- Sure, I edited it, so I know what it is.
Let's watch it (laughs).
- Okay.
- One of the objectives I have
is to play beer pong, and
win a game of beer pong.
I will have to play beer pong until I win,
because I used to win.
I haven't played beer pong in a long time.
- [Voiceover] They're chugging beers.
- We're doing it.
(high-pitched, sped-up talking)
- Good little montage.
Are you embarrassed by how important
beer pong is to you?
- I used to win beer pong all the time.
I built my own beer pong table.
It was called "The Floorboard,"
because I made it out of flooring.
Oh, well, we did it.
We got back at 4:00, or 3:45.
It was a crazy night.
We played beer pong, lost the first game.
- Damn it!
- Oh!
- Mother fucker!
You gotta be kidding me!
- Me and BWo really
embraced the true nature
of beer pong, which is
to say something together
with your partner every
time you're about to shoot.
Somehow it gets you in the zone.
(cheers off-screen)
- You did it.
I won a game of beer pong.
- [Voiceover] Finally!
- We won.
- For us to win, we had to go,
(together) "Octavarius, so nefarious."
- And it's also about the
power of touch, Henry.
It unites people.
(everyone laughs)
- Okay (mumbles).
- Me and Mark tried to chug a beer
faster than a girl.
- Yeah!
- Yeah, chug!
(everyone cheers)
- Couldn't.
Both college students beat both of us
in the chugging contest.
Mark didn't even try.
Mark just didn't try.
We went to four-square,
and in four-square, I fell down,
got a little cut there.
- It's funny how often you get hurt
while drinking when
you're young versus now.
I never get hurt.
- Yeah, because when
you're young and drinking,
you have so much more energy to go out
and attack the world,
where now if I'm drinking,
I'm like, "I'm cool to sit on this stool."
- Yeah.
I don't feel invincible anymore.
But today, we're pretty hung over.
We're gonna go eat some shepherd's pie
at an Irish pub.
That's it, right?
Did we do it?
(mumbles)
(everyone laughs)
- Yeah, so now we're getting tacos
at my favorite taco stand.
- [Voiceover] Did anything
about this experience
make you guys sad?
- The thing that I miss the most
about college is the
immediacy of all your friends,
how easy it is for 25
people that you really love
to just show up in 10 minutes.
So, that's pretty much it, you know?
We went down.
We all had pretty much the same time.
We had a lot of fun, but ultimately
we like partying how
we already party here,
which, really, is similar.
We get drunk, but we just
don't stay out as late
and we don't drink to
incredible excess anymore.
- Yeah.
- I feel like we've found
the highlights of what this can be,
and then we do those to
the best of our ability.
- That's how you party as
you get older, I guess.
- Plus, fucking tacos for days.
- Yeah, tacos for days.
- Tacos for days.
- Know that, and thanks
for watching Real Mature.
Until next time.
What it do.
- What it do.
- [all together] What it do!